so they tell us that here I'm solved the
equation five plus the square root of x
plus 14 is equal to X plus seven using
the following step so let's see what he
did he subtracted 5 from both sides yea
that's reasonable enough that got that 5
out of the way and then 7 minus 5 is 2
and then he squared both sides the
square root of x plus 14 squared is just
X plus 14 that makes sense and X plus 2
squared is X plus 2 squared and then he
used he uses the pattern for square
binomials to expand the right hand side
okay so he just multiplied out X plus 2
times X plus 2 to get x squared plus 4 X
plus 4 then he subtracted X plus 14 from
both sides so you guys gets a zero on
the left hand side so when you take X
from for X you get 3x when you take 14
from 4 you get negative 10 so that all
makes sense then you factor the
right-hand side let's see 5 times
negative 2 is negative 10 5 plus
negative 2 is 3 that makes sense then it
uses a zero product property to solve
the equation that's just this property
that look if you have two things and you
take their product and it equals zero
one or both of them must be equal to
zero so that means X plus 5 is equal to
zero or X minus 2 is equal to zero and
so if X plus 5 is equal to zero that's X
is equal to negative 5 X is equal to 2
is zero that's X is equal to 2 let me
just write that down here so all he did
in this step is he says X plus 5 is
equal to zero or X minus 2 is equal to
zero from this you get this right over
here because you subtract 5 from both
sides and then from this you get that
right over there then he checked both
answers he substituted negative 5 into
the original equation so you substitute
negative 5 in there it shows up twice 5
plus the square root of negative 5 plus
14 is equal to negative 5 plus 7 let's
see what else he did then this becomes
the square root of 9 this becomes 2 and
then you get 5 plus 3 is equal to 2
which is false this is not true and he
wrote that down and then he tried out to
his other solution when you substitute 2
you get 2 plus 14 which is 16 2 plus 7
is 9 square root of 16 is 4 and this is
the principal root of 16 were talking
about so we're taking the positive
square root and 5 plus 4 is equal to 9
so this works out and then
he says that the answer is x equals 2
which is right now this whole exercise
all they want us to know is is this an
example of deductive reasoning explain
and it is an example of deductive
reasoning he started off with a known
statement with a known we could call
that a known fact if we assume that
that's a fact he started off with that
and just doing logical operations he was
able to deduce step by step he was able
to manipulate other truths he started
with the fact and using logical
operations he was able to come up with
other facts and go all the way down here
and then check his answers and
eventually come up with the notion that
if this is true then this must also be
true so that is deductive reasoning you
start with facts use logical steps or
operations or logical reasoning to come
up with other facts he's not estimating
he's not generalizing he's not assuming
some trend will continue he's starting
with something he knows it's true and
gets to something else he knows it's
true and this is a bit of review you're
probably wondering why this why the
negative 5 wasn't a solution and it's a
little bit of a hint here and I'll let
you think about why it didn't end up as
a solution when we took the square root
of 9 here we took the positive square
root and that's what when anyone just
says a square root like that that means
the positive square root the principal
square root but if we were to take the
negative square root here this equation
would have held up because 5 plus
negative 3 is equal to 2 so I'll let you
think about at what step of this
equation would have a negative number
have worked and it has something to do
with when we square both sides but that
has nothing to do with the actual
question at hand so I'll leave you there
we've explained it before in the past so
this was deductive reasoning